[Music]
pick a fight anymore this will end badly
hi I'm Hannah and I'm the world's okay
it's mom so for the past three
trimesters
I have loved what I eat in a day I just
wanted to vlog what I eat in a day for
each trimester to show the difference
how it kind of changes and to just give
you a little insight into my weird world
of pregnancy right now so I hope you
enjoy also I should note that I am NOT a
dietitian I'm not being seen by a
dietitian so please don't take what I
eat and apply it to yourself as like the
healthy way to go I don't know if it is
I try as hard as I can and that's about
it
so hope good morning it is my first
trimester not the greatest morning
actually because first trimester for me
means waking up every day feeling like
I'm super hungover I don't get that
pukey morning sickness I get the all day
long nausea something will sound okay
and then I'll eat it and it's like oh I
should not have eaten that so I start
the morning with water I'm taking gummy
prenatals if I can sometimes I just
really can't but basically I'm living
first trimester like if it sounds good I
will eat it and if it doesn't I will not
prenatals okay I'm going to eat a flamin
hot cheeto because it sounds good oh but
if I eat any more this one badly I'm
high on to something else so another fun
thing is I can't drink coffee I cannot
stop my kick so I've been drinking tea
and the only tea that I can drink or
that I like is Earl Grey and it has to
have milk in it I used to not be a milk
in my tea kind of girl and
it has some milk in it or it doesn't sit
well either one thing that I've been
loving is first trimester is grapes I
love grapes right now I will eat this
entire bunch of grapes and then I'll
probably have a pickle in a couple hours
it is pickle time oh yeah yeah and so
this is usually my like second lunch
after my grapes I'm gonna try to drink
this protein shake while I go out and
run some errands so this is a protein
drink with greens added to it doesn't
taste great to me at least it's
something in the first trimester I
haven't really been getting much
nutrition so this is like my little hack
to try to try to get something in there
so kids are swimming and I am enjoying
some sauerkraut straight out of the jar
you want rum it really helps
my stomach actually dinnertime the one
thing that I've found that I can eat
that I like is this one Vietnamese pho
bowl from Costco this is the best thing
I've ever eaten in my entire life
really sad not being able to eat dinner
with everybody else but I will say I am
so glad I gave this a taste because
whatever is in the broth like it's a
very unique flavor it doesn't really
taste like from a restaurant it's the
best flavor right now for me so much for
my dinner so that's pretty much all my
meals for the day and then I might have
some ice cream tonight but we'll see
good morning and welcome to what I eat
in a day
second trimester okay of the pimple show
I'm feeling a lot better this trimester
honestly I feel like I'm on top of the
war hope I can tolerate a lot more foods
and so I feel like my diets gotten a lot
healthier since the first trimester I
start my day with a green smoothie and
I'm gonna show you how I make dad just
kidding I actually start my day with a
glass of water pregnancy brain makes me
forget
now you can tolerate coffee I still
drink a lot of tea but I'll have a cup
of coffee in the morning I'm still
taking prenatal gummies I'm still not
really tolerating the big pills so this
mini has half a frozen banana frozen
raspberries frozen blueberries
strawberries and my little hack is to
add frozen cauliflower and then a little
bit of Icelandic yogurt which is my new
obsession I've cut up a bunch of green
then and then some almond milk sometimes
if I'm a little extra hungry I will add
some hemp protein so usually I will take
this on the go and just drink it in the
car but since I'm home today I'm gonna
make it into a smoothie bowl with
granola my smoothie wall I just do
blueberries and granola on top mmm it's
really good
I'm getting a very late start to lunch
so I ended up just heating up this saag
paneer
it's frozen from Trader Joe's and so one
of my favorite foods right now I forgot
to finish filming so I'm continuing it
with dinner today I wanted to show you
my snack nutritious serving of mmm I'm
doing like a sweet and sour chicken I'm
doing a noodle dish with a bunch of
veggies and a bunch of broccoli in it
and the kids really like it I really
like it right now goes great with my
candy do you like this dinner Wyatt do
you like this dinner
you like this to me this is one of my
favorite dinners I love broccoli my page
is really good right now and it's nice
and salty and my blood pressure is good
so I can eat it and that is it good
morning my master okay so let's talk
about a couple things or try mist or one
look at this puff I don't really
remember if I said this about my second
trimester but I'm super anemic so I'm
taking iron supplements along with my
coming prenatals and with the iron
supplements you're not supposed to UM
have too much dairy because I guess it
prevents absorption so I'm gonna turn
out to have dairy until the second half
of the day if I do the other fun fact is
I can't stomach coffee again so I'm back
to you but with no cream cuz I drink it
in the morning
so I'm gonna take my iron pill with this
turmeric shot term right it's supposed
to help with inflammation basically
third trimester there's not as much room
in my stomach because there's
everything's filled up by baby so I'm
just eating like smaller more frequent
big snacks basically but this morning I
woke up wanting some pumpkin pancakes
and so did the kid while my pancakes
cook and drink my big glass of water
I'm still doing it I'm gonna make some
eggs and it's gonna be a great breakfast
but I can only eat only a little bit at
a time so I'll be hungry in like an hour
okay this is my plate well Apple little
pancake and syrup and an egg I'm gonna
try to eat all of this these pancakes
are so good it's about lunchtime and I
made myself a salad
the way I make myself eat salad these
days cuz it just I love salad I just
don't like it right now so what I do is
I load it up with Caesar dressing that's
hearts of palm on top cucumbers olives
and cheese and that's kind of how I
enjoy my salads right now because so I'm
gonna be everything in the world
so this mm-hmm it's a good salad not
feeling great I feel big and I'm not
sleeping well and stuff so I'm gonna
have some treats and the first one is
some chocolate milk I really want cake
my own how many cake we're in the car
while I eat this flamin hot cheeto corn
it's the best thing ever so this is
pretty much my dinner and then they'll
have dinner later
because we all need on different
schedules you want to try what are you
eating my cheeto corn
let me hot cheetos and corn this is why
i eat small meals because this fool
takes over cheese collective he dropped
his polenta so he got mine in reality
I'm actually eating credit pretty small
portions of all my food because my
family scavenges when I'm pregnant
sometimes you
I want a taste and I can't determine
what the taste is that hot cheeto corn
was the best taste I've had in a while
so it's time for my evening snack
this is Icelandic yogurt and I just
added chia seeds to that and then I'm
eating a half of an avocado with that
just because I didn't get to finish my
corn and I didn't get to finish my
Paletta so I'm gonna have that with some
sparkling water and I think that's it
for me for the day third trimester it
kind of changes every day so I'm not
gonna eat the same thing tomorrow it's
probably gonna be totally different but
this is kind of the quantity I eat and
the timing of all the food I eat it's
like a lot of fights so that's I got for
today I'm Hannah if you have any
thoughts questions comments leave them
below if you want to see anything in a
future episode while I'm still pregnant
leave that in the comments below as well
and happy eating everybody enjoy what
about anything what are you you know
your trolley meat you enjoy a bagel
treat for me okay until next time
[Music]
you are a troll